nothing about her Premiership has been
straightforward walk into a speech at
the end of a conference she'll want to
put behind her
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but whether she moves up or out who
might stop her and when the dominant
questions here Applause mask in the true
mood of this party now all pointing to
the PM to change their fortunes not easy
and she knows it these are stormy days
I'm determined to get Britain moving to
get us through the Tempest and to put us
on a stronger footing as a nation trying
to move forward but facing headwinds as
the last few weeks have shown it will be
difficult whenever there's change there
is disruption and not everybody will be
in favor of change
she was right some louder than others
protesters hijacking the hall asking if
this pm has a mandate for her radical
set of policies
let's get them removed
disruption in this room an apt ends were
difficult and divided conference
later on in my speech my friends I'm
going to talk about the anti-growth
Coalition but I think I think I think
they arrived in the hall a bit too early
but the pmu's in the moment to press on
I have three priorities for our economy
growth
growth and growth
fundamentally growth helps people
fulfill their hopes and their dreams
a Chancellor in agreement promising to
be in lockstep with one another to
reduce taxes cutting taxes is the right
thing to do morally and economically
bring down debt we will keep an iron
grip on the nation's finances I believe
in fiscal responsibility I believe in
getting value for the taxpayer and boost
growth we will drive economic reforms to
build our country for a new era a new
economic era but the political attacks
age-old I will not allow the anti-growth
coalition to hold us back
foreign
s the SMP
it's always more taxes more regulation
and more meddling
wrong wrong
and it was the country as much as her
colleague she needed to speak to a focus
on the personal not just political I
want what you want
I thought to get where I am today I've
juggled my career with raising two
wonderful daughters
I know how it feels to have your
potential dismissed by those who think
they know better
I remember as a young girl being
presented on a plane with a junior air
hostess badge Meanwhile my brothers were
given Junior pilot badges
Keen to reveal who she is but no new
announcements instead going over old
ground the Rwanda migration scheme
leveling up a promise to bust the covid
backlog and boost social care but the
biggest applause was for this Ukraine
can win Ukraine must win and Ukraine
will win
comfortable territory for a form of
foreign secretary now PM different tasks
ahead we will build a New Britain for a
new era
Liz Strauss is trying to project
strength from the people in the room
seem to like it but as she herself
acknowledged this has been a difficult
few weeks she's behind in the polls her
parties divided her problems are still
highly enough
holding her husband tight a lot was
resting on those words a PM aware of the
difficulties ahead can you like the
party prime minister outside the hall
her cabinet calling for harmony message
to back benches that are destabilizing
her so pay attention fantastic speech a
prime minister with absolute clear
determination to take us forwards
willing to take on the hard decisions
come with us it was absolutely fantastic
strong on growth showed everybody her
determination to deliver for everybody
with a really clear message about growth
Nadeem Sahari is she's stronger and
weaker after that speech what did you
think speech is about delivery and
actually growth that's what she's
focused on for now this a prime minister
trying to Shelter From The Storm in a
rush to get out and get on
but after a torrid few days this PM is
not in the driving seat Beth Rigby Sky
News in Birmingham